micra I'm just wondering if you can
begin by giving us any more detail on
what has been learned about the attack
sure I mean basically you had a
disclosure yesterday that the breach of
the Office of Personnel Management was
much larger than and then it had
initially reported last year and
includes the private and personal data
of 4 million current and former
government employees that in other words
they got just about everything I mean
that's a huge a huge number and this is
a huge hit in terms of the security of
government networks the next iteration
of that is that it appears that the same
Chinese hacking group that hit the
office of personnel management is also
responsible for a slew of hacks against
health care companies health insurers
hospital companies that have going on
for the last 18 months so it appears
that china is gathering a huge database
of personal information on government
workers and others everything from their
social security numbers to actual very
intimate things like health records
which is a kind of a scary idea Michael
Chertoff who is responsible for
safeguarding these online identities and
all of this information well of the
enterprise that holds the data has the
responsibility to safeguard it in this
case if we're talking about US
government records it was the US
government itself and what's a little
concerning about this is it appears that
the hackers were actually in the network
at the office of personnel management
and the Department of Interior for an
extended period of time which means that
it was a pretty sophisticated attack
that they were careful to cover what
they were doing as opposed to being very
noisy and obvious and it suggests that
we're dealing with a pretty
sophisticated group of actors who have
been targeting a number of enterprises
with massive databases Michael Chertoff
as a former government official do you
believe that your own personal
information is at risk obviously there
anybody who worked in the government and
recent years has their dad at risk I
think what's concerning in particular
about this is
usually a group like the group that has
been identified as the hackers here is
not simply out to harvest information
for criminal purposes but it's usually
being sponsored by the state in this
case China for a state purpose and the
question is what do they want this data
for is it in order to troll around and
see who they might identify for further
targeting is there some espionage
element to this I think these are the
issues that will preoccupied people well
Michael Chertoff based on your
experience who is better at safeguarding
the online information the US government
or private industry I'm sad to say that
nobody's really that good at it I mean
obviously there are some sectors of the
US economy that have been better than
others and are more sophisticated than
others in within the government the
military and intelligence and networks
tend to be better safeguarded than some
of the purely civilian agencies but as
we saw with the Snowden's I incident
even very sophisticated intelligence and
he can be penetrated from inside the
organization if if nothing else Mike
Reilly if this is the work of the
Chinese why are we only learning about
this now obviously the hackers know
about it the US government knows about
it who they keeping this a secret from
so if there's an interesting question
about the when this was discovered and
when was when it was disclosed
apparently the hack in the office of
personnel management was discovered in
April under state laws they have an
obligation to disclose when personal
data is taken it may have taken them a
few weeks to discover exactly what data
was taken that in fact did include this
whole group of four million people and
then they have about 30 days to disclose
that hack which may have triggered what
happened yesterday Michael Chertoff to
you if you believe that any of your
personal information that is on line is
secure well I mean I think the first
thing you need to do is to understand
that there are some things you need to
have online but some things you don't
to put online and I think everybody has
some responsibility to try to minimize
the amount of data that is placed at
risk by thinking through who they give
data to inform our purpose in this case
the data for personnel records is
obviously something you have to give the
government it's disturbing that after
the number of incidents we've had over
the past few years this was still able
to occur but I have to be honest there's
almost nothing that's impregnable it's a
question of trying to minimize the
vulnerability and to architect your
system in a way so as to mitigate the
damage Michael Chertoff is this going to
get worse with the proliferation of
mobile devices well the problem with
mobile devices is not only going to be
more pathways into databases but as we
actually operate physical control
systems using wireless devices they're
going to become vulnerable and as we
start to build that things like
driverless automobiles and similar types
of devices we better be careful to make
sure nobody can enter into those devices
and begin to actually affect their
performance in the physical world